in the entire universe the two greatest
scientific mysteries are first of all
the origin of the universe itself and
second of all the origin of intelligence
believe it or not sitting on our
shoulders is the most complex object
that Mother Nature has created in the
known universe you have to go at least
24 trillion miles to the nearest star to
find a planet that may have life and may
have intelligence and yet our brain only
consumes about 20-30 watts of power and
yet it performs calculations better than
any large supercomputer so it's a
mystery how is the brain wired up and if
we can figure that out what can we do it
to enhance our mental capabilities when
you look at the brain and all the parts
of the brain they don't seem to make any
sense at all the visual part of the
brain is way in the back for example why
is the brain constructed the way it is
is this nothing but an accident of
evolution well one way to look at it is
through evolution that is the back of
the brain is the so-called reptilian
brain the most ancient primitive part of
the brain that governs balance
territoriality mating and so the very
back of the brain is also the kind of
brain that you find in reptiles and when
I was a child I would go to the Science
Museum and look at the snakes sometimes
and they would stare back at me and I
would wonder what are they thinking
about well I think now I know what
they're thinking about was is this
person lunch then we have the center
part of the brain going forward and
that's a so-called monkey brain the
mammalian brain the brain of emotions
the brain of social hierarchies then
finally the front of the brain is the
human brain especially the prefrontal
cortex this is where rational thinking
is and when you ask yourself a question
where am i anyway the answer is right
behind your forehead that's where you
really are well I have a theory of
consciousness which tries to wrap it all
up together there have been about 20,000
or
so papers written about consciousness
and no consensus never in the history of
science have so many people devoted so
much time to produce so little well I'm
a physicist and when we physicists look
at a mysterious object the first thing
we try to do is to create a model a
model of this object in space and then
we hit the play button and run it
forward in time this is how Newton was
able to come up with a theory of gravity
this is how Einstein came up with
relativity so I tried to use this in
terms of the human brain and evolution
so what I'm saying is I have a new
theory of consciousness based on
evolution and that is consciousness is
the number of feedback loops required to
create a model of your position in space
with relationship to other organisms and
finally in relationship to time so think
of the consciousness of a thermostat I
believe that even a lowly thermostat has
one unit of consciousness that is it
senses the temperature around it and
then we have a flower a flower has maybe
maybe 10 units of consciousness it has
to understand the temperature the
weather humidity where gravity is
pointing and then finally we go to the
reptilian brain which I call level 1
consciousness and reptiles basically
have a very good understanding of their
position in space especially because
they have to lunge out and grab prey
then we have level 2 consciousness the
monkey consciousness the consciousness
of emotions social hierarchies where are
we in relationship to the tribe and then
where are we as humans as humans we are
at level 3 we run simulations into the
future animals apparently don't do this
they don't plan to hibernate they don't
plan the next day's agenda they have no
conception of tomorrow to the best of
our ability but that's what our brain
does our brain is a prediction machine
and so when we look at the evolution
from the reptilian brain to the
mammalian brain to the prefrontal cortex
we realized that is the process of
understanding our position in space with
respect to others that is emotions and
finally running simulations into the
future